the guitar becomes your passion and I
mean thank God for that it's the only
other thing in the house for Christ's
sake I mean you slept with that guitar
my correct basically yeah you would walk
around that's how I got satisfaction
because it was always within hands reach
you know how old were you when you when
you picked up your first
guitar 12 12 something like that 12
13 yeah cuz my grandfather introduced me
to cuz he had one but was it a real did
you have a realization that this might
be my ticket n not just something that
fascinated me and then when Grandpa gave
it to me and lent me and said you know
put your fingers here try this out and
then it went on from there and I said
wow I really like this but I had
absolutely no uh know preconceived
notions about playing music or anything
I mean Granddad was Gus was his name
um but what a great you must have such a
Loving Feeling for Gus I mean you K me
gave you the
guitar yeah and then he turn me on to it
and just but without pushing you know I
mean he would just say oh you he used to
keep it there was a on a shelf in his
living room and it was just there
and and one day uh I was visiting now I
used to visit every now and again um you
keep looking at that thing yeah you want
to he was basically a violinist himself
you know but he had instruments around
and he ped it off the shelf and said and
put it in my hands and said if you can
learn this little Spanish thing this
flamco thing called Malaguena of course
if you can like just it's it's quite
simple to learn to start with you know
and then you can elaborate but so if you
can learn
that you'll be able to to play guitar
you know so I went to work how many
years did you play before you started to
feel confident I know it was a few
months before I said I've got to take
this further I want to take this you
know F but the thing is that there was
no way I was going to be a Musician
musician you know going to like the
College of uh music right it just
started to come to me and uh and then I
realized what I really wanted to do
is to play with another
cat just I mean this is yeah yeah
because basically you're jerking off by
yourself but what you can do with
another cat throwing in licks and like
Counterpoint and just playing against
each other that opens up a whole world
did you find older kids to do that with
who do I find Mick Dr well Mick wasn't
Mick was a singer yes I know he wasn't
playing but through m i mean I got to
play you know he was hanging out with
other guitar players I had a couple of
friends at Art School that were playing
as well I got to say but I mean it
wasn't seriously until Mick and I hooked
that I really thought about this thing
as being ah I could take this on you
know otherwise it was just a hobby you
know and what's crazy is too you know I
was talking about this you can't have a
plan B like you just started playing
guitar hanging with these dudes you
never sat and said to well maybe I'll go
get a job at the hardware store no
you're all in I mean that's it that's
what it takes yeah yeah know there's no
possibility of doing anything else do
you play every day in other words are
you still so passionate about guitar
that like it's part of your blood and
part of your life I pick it up just
about every day and to this day after
all your years you still love it it's a
work in progress how every time you pick
the thing up there's the potential of
finding something totally new how is
that possible you know what I mean it's
the same notes it's the same
progressions it's the one note against
the other and about and the Rhythm at
the same time this is why music is so
beautiful and why kind of it's I always
said it's kind of weird to talk about
music yeah because you know if if you
could put music into words there'd be no
need for
it